hey youtubers is Charlie and yes there
was new Walking Dead this week in spite
of the fact that the ostlers Ron and it
was an amazing episode we got a deep
dive into Daryl just like me showing a
couple of weeks ago and Beth had a very
special first moment that she'd been
waiting to have for a long time quick
shout out to my giveaway if you are
finding me for the first time just to
say thank you to all you guys for being
so awesome each week I select a random
subscriber from the comments on these
videos to give a $20 Amazon gift card to
that's just the review videos I'll
announce who it is in my Q&A video
tomorrow but all you have to do is leave
a comment be a subscriber and you have
to be nice so let's do our top five
moments from the episode and then I'll
do my review careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet here we go
number 5 the opening scene in the trunk
the combination of it being super dark
and stormy and then just listening to
Walker's pile on top of the car was so
intense and just the perfect way to
start an episode like this I loved that
when they finally came they just got out
shrug it off and continue down the road
like it was just another day in Walker
paradise number 4 best first drink of
course the last thing left in the
apocalypse would be peach schnapps no
one would want to drink it no matter how
desperate they are for booze this was
actually a really funny scene just
because Beth was so determined to get
that first drink until she broke down I
actually kind of thought that it was
only because she wanted to drink but
really she needed that drink I think
that moment where Daryl smashed the
bottle was him just helping her keep her
dignity a little bit like he was
genuinely trying to be nice be nice for
Daryl is not quite the same thing as
being nice for you and me though but
it's the thought that counts number
three the drinking game
how awesome was it that not only did
they find Daryl's dad's cabin but that
it was packed with moonshine it really
makes you feel geographically like they
haven't traveled that far I kept getting
a hookup vibe from the two of them and
the drinking game which was hilarious
seemed like it was all about Beth
putting a move on Daryl after she got
too drunk I was really happy when things
didn't go that way instead though it led
to something way cooler number two Daryl
loses his [ __ ]
Daryl is a hard man to read Norman
Reedus does such a good job of playing
emotions under the skin you could kind
of tell what Daryl was thinking based on
his grunts and shrugs but when Beth
finally got him to admit how bad he was
really feeling it was so satisfying I
kind of viewed all these cabin scenes as
his
version of the scene Michonne got two
weeks ago with the flashbacks to her
baby
although Daryl opted to resolve his
feelings about the past in a much more
spectacular fashion and my number one
moment
no surprise here burning the cabin down
let me know if you also feel like Beth
has become the collective consciousness
of their little group but now she's kind
of operating Daryl like a finger puppet
not in a bad way
but she was basically his psychiatrist
through that entire cabin part of the
episode she identifies his problems and
then helps him find closure look at how
much she's grown up and she can even
kill the [ __ ] out of walkers I love that
she said I'm not like those other girls
but I survived
Beth is officially way cooler than Daryl
Dixon right now at least until he finds
another poncho but let me know what your
favorite moment from the episode was and
if Maggie and Sasha's group is also in
the next episode do you think that means
that they're going to meet up with them
I think it's gonna end up being like the
episode where Rick and Carl were in the
same episode with me shown and they
ended up meeting up overall the episode
was a plus amazing really this was the
first day plus I think I've ever given
to any episode of this season I was
watching this while I also had the
Oscars on in the background and if you
also skip the Oscars for this I can tell
you you made the right call
I love how Walking Dead has used these
post-prison group-based episodes to give
us all this new information about
characters past like learning what
teenage Daryl was like turns out wasn't
all that Pleasant but I think we already
kind of suspected that Beth on the other
hand has been a wonderful surprise
I'm so glad she's a badass now it just
means that there'll be so many more
opportunities for comedy with those two
I really hope that they could continue
to have a special bond after meeting
back up with the other person people
kind of like Carl and me shown have just
like Beth said she's different than
everyone else so I don't think that
she'll end up being like Carol or lawyer
or even was shown in the future right
now she seems like she's going to be the
one to take over Herschel's role as the
moral center of the show even though all
the group's probably won't completely
reunite by the end of the season Lizzie
on the other hand is turning into
something of a female governor we need
to keep our eyes peeled on her so love
or hate the episode be sure to sound off
in the comments like I said I'm not also
gonna try and post an Oscar winner
analysis video way later tonight it'll
probably be pretty late and that Q&A
video will post tomorrow with the
giveaway winner right now click here for
my oscar video and click here for my Q&A
video thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you